Herbert P VIX author of Hirohito and the
making of modern Japan could somebody
who is Japanese write this book and
publish it through a Japanese publisher
in Japan today I think so
I think today there has been a number of
breakthroughs that have occurred over
the past 20 years and Hirohito has died
died 10 years ago
so enough time has elapsed it's possible
and I would expect and in fact I would
hope that Japanese historians will
surpass this biography and uncover new
material and that we will get critical
accounts of the Emperor and the role he
played both before during and after the
war because that man is absolutely
crucial for understanding the dilemmas
of 20th century Japan there's a picture
in here and you write about it in your
book what's the importance of this
picture right now
General MacArthur in his first meeting
with Emperor Hirohito at the American
Embassy where Hirohito travelled to meet
him is posed as a triumphant in general
with his hands in his back pockets
beside an emperor who is the symbol of a
vanquished nation and the Japanese
people at the time that photograph was
taken when they finally got to see it
it drove home to them the reality of the
new situation they confronted occupation
by the foreign enemy you say in your
book that that picture wasn't published
right away what were the circumstances
what year was it this is late September
1945
and the home ministry interdicted the
picture regarded as lasing majesty and a
photograph that would undermine the
prestige of the throne it must not be
circulated and so the papers were
confiscated all the newspapers had
carried the picture and this led General
MacArthur to issue his famous Civil
Liberties Edict of October 4 I believe
at that time not only did MacArthur
abolish the peace preservation bar of
1925 which you know sort of consolidated
the restrictions on freedom of press and
assembly
he released political prisoners from the
jails and with the threat of punishment
for criticism of the Emperor removed you
begin to get in the first few weeks of
October
continuing mushrooming as the months
unfold thereafter annex Lud of
publications criticizing the war leaders
because mind you from the moment of
Japan's surrender on August 15th until
late September the Japanese people were
prevented from criticizing their wall
leaders and and
the whole apparatus of repression was in
place and thought police thought
procurator's were busy maintaining the
Emperor's rule and I think Mikasa with
that Civil Liberties edict took the
first crucial step of course he had
already ordered on September 11th a few
weeks before Hirohito came to the palace
the arrests of suspected class-a war
criminals including the wartime Prime
Minister the man who had taken Japan as
Prime Minister into war against the US
Britain and the Netherlands general Tojo
Hideki and this marks the beginning of a
series of arrests of men who would stand
trial under the terms of the Potsdam
Declaration which Japan accepted when it
capitulated and unconditionally accepted
the terms that would go into effect a
couple of lose track of time but John
dower was here a year or so ago he had
won the National Book Award on a book
about Japan here you are just a year
later you won the Pulitzer Prize yes I
must say that John also won the Pulitzer
Prize what is it about your book do you
think got the Pulitzer Prize judges to
give you the award that's a hard
question I think that the award may be
seen as acknowledgement recognition of
the fact that the effort needed to be
made I had made it to find out the truth
about the Showa Emperor and the role he
played in the war and that the
confrontation with the past history and
memory is very important for Japan at
this juncture when
the Japanese governments including the
new Co Izumi Junichi doe government
insists on approving for use in the high
schools and junior high schools
textbooks that whitewash very key
aspects of the Asia Pacific War I think
that at a time when the Japan's leaders
continue to maintain for home
consumption the view of the lost war is
sort of a holy war on the one hand and a
war of self-defense righteous war for
self defense and self preservation but
for external consumption they you know
pay lip service to the fact that it was
a war of aggression when you have this
double standard being perpetuated in
Japan it's not only harmful I think to
Japan's relations with its Asian
neighbors but it is a burden that
prevents Japan from getting on with its
other important tasks in the new century
so I think that the the pulitzer award
in the background today what move the
men who made and women who made that
decision to give me the award is this
whole context of a Japan that's
grappling with history and memory and
and needs all the help we can get even
if it comes from a foreigner now you
dedicate this book to Toshi and my
grandchildren yes to my wife and to my
grandchildren
who's Toshi my wife she Japanese she was
a Japanese born an American citizen and
the grandchildren are they here in this
country yes my grandchildren in fact
there
their way to Vermont as I speak right
now to visit their grandparents how did
you meet a wish you said she was born
here my wife was Japanese born born in
Japan and became a naturalized American
citizen in the late 1960s
how did that happen how did you meet her
I met my wife when I first came to Japan
as a young naval officer in the service
squadron attached the seventh Fleet and
one of the first things I did when I
arrived in Yokosuka Japan the big naval
base was to go into Tokyo my ship was at
sea at the time I'd missed it so I went
in to the city and I saw some very
interesting sights I met my wife shortly
afterward so what did it what happened
to your life when you married someone
who was Japanese well I think it
improved my life it's civilized me it
opened my eyes I've been interested in
Japan but you know through my wife and
her family I came to appreciate Japan in
a different way how long have you lived
there in your life
well altogether I would say
nearly 15 years at different times and I
this past April I returned to the United
States after three and a half years of
living in Japan have you talked to many
Japanese in a read your book indeed I
have and my book came out late last
August beginning of September 2000 and
bucks weren't available at that time in
Japan but I began a book tour there many
Japanese ordered it on the web and began
to read the book and I received
letters and postcards and they kept
coming for the past year and so I would
say the response has been overwhelmingly
positive I learned as well that there is
a segment of the older generation of
Japanese who had visceral dislike of the
Showa Emperor Hirohito something I had
not anticipated but they considered him
a moral coward for not having abdicated
and taken responsibility for the war
fought in his name the lost war which he
had energized and made to appear as a
moral endeavor let me read from the back
of your book and in a lot of comments
from different people who basically have
endorsed the book but Chalmers Johnson
who is he by the way Chalmers Johnson is
Professor Emmett hrus University of
California he's retired and he's the
head of the Japan Policy Research
Institute and a very prolific public
intellectual very important figure I
think he says reading Herbert vixx's
pioneering inquiry indeed Emperor
Hirohito's life should make Americans
angry yes stop there's more to read but
why would it make Americans angry well
he is referring there to the post war
cover-up of Hirohito's role in the war
and the way I think in which Americans
obstructed the Japanese effort to come
to terms with their lost war this begins
during the occupation at the very outset
when General MacArthur arrived in Japan
II already had made up his mind to use
the Emperor for his own purposes which
were to affect the terms of the Potsdam
Declaration demócrata DeMille
demilitarized Japan democratize it the
emperor would be his puppet he imagined
just as in the 1930s Japanese generals
imagine that they could use Hirohito he
was an empty vessel and they could fill
him up as they please now of course
Hirohito proved to be a survivor and is
skilled in his negotiations with the
Americans General MacArthur in
particular as he had been in dealing
with his Admirals and Generals during
the first half of the 1930s when it
seemed that the military was on such a
rapid rise that if the military would
elude control overall control and I
argue one of the themes of this book is
that the Showa Emperor's life during its
the first 20 years of his life from 1926
down to 1945 illustrates the tendency of
military power to expand in any quality
when democratic institutions are absent
or non-functioning the voices of
ordinary people are shut out of the
policy-making process and and and there
is no institutional restraint on the
Armed Forces other than a lacks are
indulgent chief executive and Hirohito
approved quite often to be elack's and
indulgent chief executive but when I
wrote those words from the introduction
to the book I also had in mind
present-day
United States because I've been very
concerned with the fact that our own
Pentagon seems to be unrestrained by
an executive that has the ability and
the intention to curb and to restructure
our forces militarism can occur in any
country and although a comparative
dimension is to be found in my book and
Japan u.s. comparative dimension
comparative history
it's recessed into the background but
it's always there I'm thinking of the
us-japan relationship because I don't
consider it to be a healthy relationship
and I felt this way for a long time
after many many decades in Japan studies
I feel that the influence of the
military in shaping our policy to Japan
is excessive and I in telling the story
of Hirohito and the rise of militarism
in a nation that whose people had
historically for centuries not been
militaristic and and and in telling this
story I I thought that there would be
lessons for Americans if I didn't
present those lessons with a heavy hand
and recess them into the book are you
still teaching yes I am at Binghamton
University I was at Stasi Bashi
University in Tokyo until March 31st I
came back to this country April 2nd and
in the fall I will take up my teaching
duties at Binghamton University in New
York that's part of the State University
of New York where I once taught in it's
wonderful place where are you from
originally I was born and grew up in
Boston I live in a little town near the
airport called Winthrop and where did
you go to school I went to school at the
University of Massachusetts and Amherst
and upon graduation I enlisted in the
Navy I went to Officer Candidate School
I instantly I receive messages email
mess
Edge's from my old boss the chief
engineer on my second ship after the
book came out how long did you serve in
the Navy four years of active duty what
year in the reserves
I think it's 1960 was at OCS in late
fall early winter of 1960 graduated the
beginning of 61 and I got out of the
Navy in I guess February of 1964 and I
entered Harvard graduate school several
months later that fall what what
impacted your experience in the United
States Navy have on the way you feel
about the military here in the military
in Japan well I had good experiences in
the Navy you know and I look back on
those years when I was very young but
the being in the Navy alerted me to the
security relationship with Japan the
us-japan security treaty which went into
effect in 1952 you know right after the
San Francisco peace treaty and it was
renewed against much a popular
opposition in 1960 and thereafter it was
renewed automatically the most recent
revision to the Treaty of the guidelines
Japan us guidelines but my point here is
that our security relationship with the
US is been dominated by the Pentagon and
we have an implantation of a hundred
thousand or maybe close to that troops
military personnel in the Far East and
in on the island of Okinawa where most
of them are they aren't generally
welcomed by the
people of Okinawa we have serious
adjustments to make in our relationship
with Japan but they can only be made by
a chief executive who is not self
indulgent not lacks and is very
committed to restructuring American
forces so I hope that readers of my book
who will understand from it what
Japanese militarism was all about and
and what happens when a nation is choose
militarism and the benefits to be gained
from doing so I hope that some readers
many readers huh we'll pick this up how
long did it take you to do your book I
spend ten years on the book and I
continued the research until January of
2000 because of the kindness of my
publisher where did you do most of the
research I did most of the research in
Japan although there were long periods
when I would be home in winthrop and I
would be working at the harvard
university libraries but for the most
part the research was done if I was not
at the National Archives in Washington I
was working in Cambridge and then I was
in Japan initially on as a Fulbright
research scholar in 1990-91 I believe
and then I did extensive rewriting of
the manuscript over the past three and a
half years while it starts about
University in Tokyo do you speak
Japanese yes I do and you read it yes I
do what advantage do you have and doing
your research because you read it and
speak it well you can interact with
people and you can read the documents
and you must over 95% of all the sources
cited in the end notes and Japanese
sources
and that's one reason why up to now even
the right-wing the nationalist Japanese
press has been circumspect and careful
in reviewing my book because it's not so
easy to criticize when most of the
sources are Japanese sources I excavated
and built on the basis of the fruits of
half a century of Japanese scholarship
it was out there most of the material
was out there it it's true after
Hirohito died in January 1989 there was
a vast outpouring of new materials
diaries memoirs of people who had worked
with him and had some sense of the man
and I including his brother one of his
brothers Prince Takamatsu and I used
these diaries and memoirs as they came
out so the book reflects on the life of
an individual who was absolutely key to
under a key absolutely a key to
understanding the dynamics of Japanese
military and political politics during
the 20th century what's new in your book
that's never been published before what
are the conclusions well in every
chapter there are some things that are
new except to a tiny handful of Japanese
scholars who specialize in this area but
what is new in the book generally
speaking is I offer a hero emperor
hirohito who was not a passive puppet of
the militarist not a bystander silent
bystander of events unfolding around him
and an individual who
was also not a normal constitutional
monarch in any conceivable Western sense
of the term the emperor I describe is
dynamic activists hands-on
interventionist individual struggling to
ensure that his role in policymaking
gets registered but of course from
beginning to end I stress he is not a
dictator he is not a Hitler or Mussolini
now must he ever be compared to them in
in that sense nor did the army or the
military ever establish a dictatorship
in Japan but Hirohito was an active
participant who in 1941 very late in the
day enters into a de facto alliance with
the hardliners in the Army and Navy and
it's that de facto alliance that allows
him allows Japan to go to war to attack
Pearl Harbor and the British Terra
Malaya at Kota Bharu what's different
between what you found and what others
have found up to this point well a great
deal the Emperor I present is an
individual who has been given a military
education he's thriving at the same time
to perform as a benevolent monarch in
Confucian sense he is an individual torn
by tensions of all sorts he's a nervous
high-strung man something of a martinet
and he's a stubborn man and yet he has a
capacity for adjusting and for
tolerating institutional change
he overturns all sorts of precedents
established by his grandfather and
primigi the man who
helped lead in Japan into the modern era
and Hirohito turns Maggie's image on its
head
who was Meiji Meiji was his grandfather
who was a young boy in 1867 sixty-eight
ascended the throne and it was in his
name that the modern Japanese state was
constructed by individuals like Ito
Hirobumi is this meiji up top in the
topic yes yes who you're pointing to
that's in and out who's below and below
there we see little Hirohito and his
brother Prince Chichibu I believe which
one is a Eurasian I have to look put on
my glasses and look holding his hand the
adult standing erect and holding his
hand is his own father who would become
the taisho emperor and in my book I
point out that I show had been ill
chronically ill since birth and there
were long periods when he was healthy
and when when this picture was taken
this is one but a few years after taisho
became emperor his mental health
deteriorated rapidly and the man was not
able to perform as a monarch let alone
perform his constitutional duties as
commander in chief and so he's removed
from the scene so to speak and Hirohito
is grows up he's educated in that period
from the russo-japanese war of 1904 and
5 when Japan is recognized as a great
regional power in East Asia down to the
end of World War 1 and those years that
Hirohito was receiving his education his
father is
and gradually withdrawing from more and
more performance of his ceremonial
duties and the monarchy in Japan is
becoming a something like a true
constitutional monarchy in other words a
passive monarch not into the not able
and not intervening in the political
process which is being conducted by
elders gendell as they were called now
Hirohito is brought up to retrieve the
lost prerogatives of the throne
prerogatives his father had been too ill
to perform and in November 1921 Hirohito
becomes region for his father he serves
for five years as regent during this
period the political parties and
gradually rising to influence and
Japan's governments are coalition
governments of civilian and military
figures but by the time Hirohito becomes
emperor in December 1926 Japan has
entered what was called the period of
the high tide of paddy cabinets and I
argue in the book again another novel
thesis that Hirohito by his insistence
on playing his constitutionally mandated
role in having a say in policy decisions
albeit behind the scenes he helps to
complicate the conduct of party
cabinet politics and undermine it and
eventually he does undermine it and
Hirohito is soon shows that he's more
comfortable dealing with bureaucratic
types than with party politicians when
you say Showa
Emperor what does that mean well the
practice of
ascribing to a reigning emperor a name
the name for his arif from the moment he
assumes the throne Meiji is given the
name his knee is M promote sahih toe
Meiji is his posthumous name but the era
is Meiji and to the era for Hirohito and
the error for Hirohito is Showa and his
posthumous name is the Showa Emperor
what's an emperor an emperor is a
monarch why don't the King know they're
here they're very distinctive they they
take the Chinese name son of heaven and
they adopt this term and pretend all is
the japanese term Tendo son of heaven
they adopt this very late in the day
that is to say when the modern monarchy
is constructed and it is a new monarchy
and it is constructed through stages and
it's constantly being reconstructed this
in this process they finally fix on the
term son of heaven Tendo Emperor rather
than king a monarch to set their ruler
apart from all other rulers it's a very
anachronistic thing but Japanese
Emperor's weren't called Tenno a son of
heaven through long stretches of history
other many other names were used for
them you write in your book that as soon
as he was born he was handed off to
somebody else to raising yes he has what
to us would seem a sort of bizarre
upbringing he's read apart from his
parents in a detached palace but this
doesn't mean that this little boy is
denied the
the warmth of concerned parents his
father and mother care for him very much
but from an early age it is true he's
taken and entrusted to an admiral to be
given a modern type of rearing and that
was considered in those days the
military was the forefront of
modernization and the young Hirohito
what was to be the first very first
emperor a reared and educated under the
modern imperial system because for
hundreds of years for Emperor's had been
removed from politics and they were
encouraged to study poetry write poetry
but to take no interest in political
affairs now Hirohito's great-grandfather
was an exception and Meiji of course was
the exception but neither of them were
educated under the modern imperial
system I might add one other thing and
that is that Japan's leaders regarded
the imperial institution as a fragile
institution we in the West see it as
going back thousands of years which
indeed is true but it it's a new
institution that is created new
traditions created in the course of
Japan's modernization lived from 1901 to
1989 his son Akihito is currently the
Emperor just briefly the difference
between Akihito and Hirohito in terms of
power
well Akihito's has no political power
and couldn't do the same thing in his
father data if it came to war no never
he's been stripped of all political
power he's not even a normal
constitutional monarch he's not even a
head of state he is defined in the
Constitution as a symbol of the unity
of the nation so by inclination by
education by his intellectual
capabilities he's a completely different
individual from his father Hirohito's
wife how did he get a wife it was an
arranged marriage from she was selected
this is a picture of Hirohito with his
brothers and his mother how old is he in
this picture and I would again I would
have to take off my glasses and look
closely but he seems to be in early
manhood probably about 9 19 20 years old
but when he when he will he had an
arranged marriage did I read correctly
that somebody found out that his wife
came from a colorblind family and they
wanted to stop it and yes and and there
was a an effort to stop it at the
forefront of this effort was the leading
military figure the father of the modern
Japanese Imperial Army Yamagata Adi Tomo
but he was supported by very other
prominent elder statesmen and he lost
out and it he ran into a terrifically
strong opposition and I tell that story
and in so doing I use it to reveal the
lineup of new political forces in Japan
after World War one forces that were
going to grow and take Japanese
nationalism in new directions
what were the aggressions of the
Japanese and were they all aggressions
on their part
well Japanese nationalism is radicalized
not in isolation
but in process of interaction with the
rise of Chinese nationalism in the early
decades of the 20th century particularly
after World War one Japan before that
time is taking part in a Western order
imposed on East Asia by the leading
imperialist powers particularly Britain
than the United States and Germany and
France and Japan is a member and as a
member of this new newly emergent
international order it makes its debut
on the international scene when it goes
to war with Qing China in 1894 did you
say that America was imperialist yes
America was took pod at the end of the
19th century in the rush for territory
in East Asia this was the period in
which the leading American military
thinker was Admiral say in Mahan Admiral
Mahan's with his theories of sea power
and a forward deployment of American
ships bases and the United States as you
know seizes Hawaii at the end of the
19th century it fights a war with Spain
it seizes the Philippines wake Guam and
Midway Islands the Japanese come on the
scene as late starting imperialists they
seize territory from China in 1895 but
the great powers France Germany and
Russia
Cyrus Russia forced Japan to return the
little Peninsula lay out on peninsular
at the foot of Mactan province and
Japan does however acquire the island of
Taiwan then known as Formosa as a result
of its first war with China and a decade
later I might add in it also secures
indemnities from China's Ching dynasty
five years later it Japan takes part in
putting down an insurrection in North
China rompe king the boxer uprising and
it was secures more rights from China
which are underwritten by the other
great powers who are also taking part
and then five years four years later it
goes to war with Cyrus Russia who was
moved into China's three northeastern
provinces Manchuria was then called and
Japan fights the war to a standstill
American President Teddy Roosevelt helps
to arbiter a peace treaty the Portsmouth
peace treaty and out of that war Japan
becomes both an insular power and a
continental power that say it acquires a
foothold on the Chinese continent
when is it colonized Korea edie
colonizes Korea five years after this
the end of the russo-japanese war and it
first establishes a protectorate and
then it takes the huge step of actually
annexing Korea and so now Japan is even
more of a continental power it's
expanded and has strategic burdens that
are going to prove very onerous but
Japan is still part of a Western
imperialist order in East Asia
then comes World War one the Germans are
knocked out of this order and a new
international framework for relations
among the great powers is constructed at
Versailles and a few years later at the
Washington conference that President
Harding
hosted here in Washington and Japan is a
member in good standing of that new
international order and it's saying that
it will abide by the new peace code and
respect for treaties the Covenant of the
League of Nations and then in 1928 the
kellogg-briand pact that outlaws
aggressive war Japan's all part of that
and it signs on it had signed on earlier
to the Hague conventions governing
ground warfare and all so when Japan
begins Japan Marie emerges as an
expansionist power in the 1930s it does
so as a revisionist power it wants
revision of this Versailles Washington
system it wants to acquire territory and
raw materials it feels that the United
States in particular has rolled back
Japan's gains and it feels aggrieved and
it's in this context of a rising sense
of aggrieved nation ilysm that the
depression comes the military make their
move Hirohito becomes emperor in
December 26 and within two years he's
facing the situation of a
insubordination in US Armed Forces and I
take the story from there in its and in
seven chapters I look very closely at
how he performs today the United States
has 284 million people on earth there
abouts Japan has about 125 million yes
I'm not quite sure but I would imagine
yes today's gross national product here
in the United States is close to ten
trillion dollars in Japan is close to
five trillion dollars it's the number
two economy still even after a decade of
economic stagnation reason I use those
fears to ask you back in 1941 what was
the you know what have any idea what
that Japan produced 1/12 the steal of
the United States I have
all those statistics in the footnote but
as it related as Japan related to the
United States then a population and
gross national product was as as similar
as it is today
oh no no no Japan was a late developing
country economically a far inferior to
the US and enormous ly dependent on the
United States for all of its strategic
raw materials when you talk about the
emperor and from time to time you allude
to this in your book that there was a
mystique that was built up around him
including what do they do there is
limousine I mean they purified the
limousine that he wrote in that was he a
deity as far as they of Japanese people
yes from the moment of his in completion
of his enthronement rights in November
1928 Hirohito is regarded that the
Japanese people are encouraged to regard
him as a living deity although he
himself didn't think that that was the
case he knew better but he felt it was
efficacious for people to believe what
would he do then if how did he live
differently how did he live well he
lived a life in isolation from the
Japanese people they saw him when he
went on tour they but they also saw him
as a family man that that picture on the
right shows him in the late 1930s when
war has begun in China I think is I
don't know I can't see the date on that
picture but a family man but he they
also see him and they see him primarily
as the supreme commander thank you 39
that was 1939 that's right then Japan
has been at war with China full-scale
war for three nearly three years but if
you lived in Japan at the time what did
you see of him did did you hear him did
he talk did he know you didn't hear his
voice you would he would come forth in
Tyrael Reis Crips and the papers would
we report the emperor taking part in an
imperial conference once that
institution was re-established and he
operated behind the scenes in a system a
pluralistic system of decision-making
whereby he was always responding to it
was made to appear that he was
responding to sanctioning decisions made
by the Cabinet but the reality was a
Hirohito Hirohito taking part in a
system of decision-making that diverged
more and more from the Meiji
Constitution a system of decision making
in which he would receive informal
reports on what was being planned what
was being discussed and he would freely
make his views known
and then at particular times he would
come forward in a more visible way and
put his imprimatur his seal on the
documents now all orders to the Armed
Forces
you know fleet commanders and field
commanders were read by him and sealed
by him and he was very fussy very
careful about what he approved and what
he disapproved the public think he was
doing that at the time the from about
1936 a great propaganda effort is
mounted to present Hirohito as a shin Se
direct ruler of the man who is ruling
the nation directly and as the war in
China drags on and Hirohito finds that
he
he's most effective performing in his
role as Supreme Commander this comes
close to the reality but the the point
to bear in mind also is that in 1930s
particularly late 1930s Japan there was
great division disagreement among the
ruling elites it was Hirohito's task to
impose some unity to make sure that the
flow of policy continued and in the
early 30s that had been continual acts
of military insubordination attempted
coup d'etats when the army moved to
seize Manchuria on September 18th 1941
Hirohito knew he had heard rumors that
things were fought and he'd a few weeks
earlier warned his top commanders to
make sure nothing happened but once it
happened once it happened he struggled
for a few years to get on top of things
this is a little bit out of context but
I it has to do with your research on it
and on page 534 you have something from
Akihito Akihito's diary the war has
ended and Hirohito's son who had been
now emperor may I see what page is this
five five thirty four five and the
reason I bring it up is it's you say
here that he's 11 years old in September
of 1945 and I was struck when I read it
about what he said this is Japan however
had been defeated and this these are the
words Akihiko because of the
overwhelming material superiority of
Britain and the United States and the
great skillfulness of the American Way
of fighting the anglo-americans were
defeated at the start because they were
not then adequately prepared but once
they were prepared they came at us like
wild boars he actually wrote that at its
eleventh eye this
was probably he was probably tooted to
some extent but I one doesn't know he
says their methods of attack meeting the
Americans were very skillful yeah
finally they used atomic bombs and
killed and wounded hundreds of thousands
of Japanese destroyed towns and
factories in the end we could fight no
longer the cause for this was the
inferiority of Japanese national power
and scientific power yes yes and that
current Emperor now wrote that when he
was eleven years old yes apparently he
wrote it these were letters written of
course he's reflecting the views of his
to disease as I say you know these
eleven he's still 11 years old it's it's
remarkable all the things that you found
yes what was the most helpful for you
when did you find the document that you
said this gives me the real insight into
Hirohito well it came early you know the
book grew to some extent out of the
diary published in 1990 by the vice
grand Chamberlain Kinoshita Michio which
contained documents in it purporting to
be you know excerpts from dictation by
the Emperor at the end of the war the
monologue of the Emperor was the single
most important document in that this
dictated account Hirohito's account of
the war which was dictated with a view
to presenting it to General MacArthur
so that MacArthur would then be
fortified with the emperor's view of the
war mind you in between March and April
of 1946 efforts were underway to
established the International Military
Tribunal for the Far East who known as
the Tokyo trial and people were being
interviewed and Tara gated to stand
trial Hirohito and those close to him
were taking pod and selecting them the
Japanese who would actually be indicted
Hirohito had to give his account of the
loss war and that document when it
became available in the West and in
Japan caused the sensation I wrote a
long article about it and out of this in
the course of writing and I said this is
my next big project this will be my book
when you researched and you researched
Japanese did you write it in English or
I wrote it in English yes has this been
translated into Japanese it's being
translated now and hopefully it will
come out next summer from Kodansha I
know many journalists have written that
the book isn't gonna be published in
Japan or might not be but within a
relatively short time my publishers
secured the leading chat one of the
leading Japanese publishers to do the
work
kodachi also operates the United States
that's right that's a very good
publisher when do you think it will hit
the bookstores and Japan next summer and
I hope I'll be over there what do you
want to do about that I mean you're
gonna go over there and do a book tour
their dependent she has the fact that
you when you first publish this book in
2000 did the local papers cover it in no
you're not at first it was neglected at
first and and then what the Japanese did
they do this so often they picked up the
Western press oh this book is causing a
furor in the United States and Europe
and Singapore and the Philippines and
elsewhere in Asia and they wrote stories
about it only later did I yeah could
World War two happen again from the
Japanese standpoint could they ever do
what they did then no I don't why not
well I don't think history will repeat
itself like that and the Japanese and a
military
people and the whole situation is
different and if they ever come to have
they ever come to admit that the
atrocities oh yes oh yes indeed they
have they have but but they say there's
censorship of the textbook it's it's a
struggle that goes on the new Prime
Minister has indicated quois Prime
Minister Koizumi Junichiro has indicated
enough adjustment of our textbook in
response to foreign precious but that's
him I how long he can maintain this I
don't know but I think that the Japanese
people do have a realistic understanding
of the aggressive nature of the war they
fought what was the hardest part of
Danis book for you getting good material
on Hirohito where was her material
refused you it was yeah it's hard to get
material it's hard to get material how'd
he do it well I relied on the publish
record I I went to different archives I
didn't bother to go to the Imperial
Household agency because I knew I would
get nowhere dealing with those people
well and they're located where in Tokyo
how would they deal with you
well they I don't know I didn't bother
why do you mean if you bothered they
wouldn't give you the time of day well I
did make some attempts indirectly the
Japanese Imperial house is not an open
Imperial house it's not like the British
monarchy you don't go traipsing through
the corridors of the palace on specified
days to visit the everything is done to
protect the privacy of the imperial
family when I spoke at the National
Press Club in Tokyo the Japan National
Press Club
I said to the journalists there that
those materials pertaining to the Showa
Emperor his diary and everything about
him too
during the war and the materials of the
privy councils office that is the
property of the nation it's not the
private property of one family and it
belongs to the nation and you
journalists should demand it in the end
this $35 book 800 pages how many copies
were printed and put into the
marketplace
well the it's gone through 8 printings
they'll be it'll come out in many
languages I I would assume over 50,000
and 52,000 copies are in print and when
do you pick up the Pulitzer Prize when
did I get the Pulitzer Prize you gotten
it in your hand yeah oh yes
how long ago a few months ago in New
York here's the book our guest has been
Herbert Nicks and the title of this book
is Hirohito and the making of modern
Japan thank you very much Thank You mr.
lamb for having me